[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com I'm back from my trip it's
really me I'm here and I'll talk about
my trip on the bonus show but sort of a
bummer to have to start my first show
back with something so disgusting and
despicable but this is the reality of
what's going on if you want to get a
sense really an actual real sense of
where the Trump administration is going
militarily you have only to look at Mike
Pence's speech over the weekend to West
Point graduates I'm going to show you a
clip today which cuts really to the
heart of neoconservative american
right-wing military aggression this is
the worst of the worst of the United
States this is a prime example of why so
many around the world are disgusted with
us listen closely to this one because
it's not getting the attention that it
deserves this is a from a speech that
Mike Pence gave over the weekend at West
Point which is a military academy it's
one of five US service academies which
are undergraduate schools for
commissioned officers in the military in
the case of West Point when they
graduate they have an eight year
commitment five years of active duty and
then three years in the reserves and
that's relevant for what we're about to
hear Mike Pence spoke to the graduating
class a few days ago and effectively let
slip that multiple wars are in play and
that graduates of West Point should
expect to be joining those wars Paul
Waldman caught this and wrote it up in
the Washington Post and I went back and
looked at the transcript and it's
sickening take a listen to what Mike
Pence said it's a virtual certainty that
you will fight on a battlefield for
America at some point your life you will
lead soldiers in combat
it will happen some of you will join the
fight against radical Islamic terrorists
in Afghanistan and Iraq some of you will
join the fight on the Korean Peninsula
and in the indo-pacific where North
Korea continues to threaten the peace
and an increasingly militarized China
challenges our presence in the region
some of you will join the fight in
Europe where an aggressive Russia seeks
to redraw international boundaries by
force and some of you may even be called
upon to serve in this hemisphere and
when that day comes I know you will move
to the sound of the guns do your duty
and you will fight it will happen
Afghanistan and Iraq I thought we were
out of Afghanistan and Iraq other than
exploring what our presence might be
nevermind combat the Korean Peninsula
against North Korea or against a
militarized China what we should be
expecting that we're going to fight in
Europe Mike Pence is talking about
fighting in Europe this hemisphere which
to me means Latin America my mind goes
in the immediate to Venezuela but there
are other possibilities
and as Paul Waldman points out in the
Washington Post piece Pence is saying
not just that more Wars are inevitable
in some general sense he's talking about
their inevitability during the time that
these West Point graduates are going to
be either in active or reserve duty now
the defenders will say I know what
they're gonna come out and say David
Pence isn't being specific fence isn't
predicting he's simply saying these are
commissioned officers who lead troops
they are statistically likely to see
combat well that's not true it has not
been statistically likely that West
Point grads see combat and Pence is not
speaking in generalities he's talking
about combat in Afghanistan and Iraq two
places were supposedly leaving into a
degree have left and the debate really
has been about should or shouldn't the
US have a presence there and what should
it look
and for how long Mike Pence is talking
about combat leading troops in Iraq and
Afghanistan this should be front page
news pence is talking about the Korean
Peninsula and China
remember that Trump said we'll talk
about North Korea again today by the way
Trump said we won't need combat with
North Korea because Kim jong-un is such
a good guy and so trustworthy and a
sense of humor and his intelligence and
everything is just so lovely and Trump
trusts him despite the continued missile
launches which we will get to
and yet Pence is saying you should
expect that inevitably some of you are
going to end up in a combat zone in the
Korean Peninsula maybe involving an
increasingly militarized China and then
Europe I mean you're a which we could do
an entire show on pence talking about
that as well so eight years it's an
eight year commitment for these
graduates after they finish up their
four years at West Point five years of
active duty three years in the reserves
and Mike Pence is saying it's very
likely that in those eight years they
will see combat in some combination of
Iraq Afghanistan China North Korea
Europe and he says this hemisphere I'm
hearing Latin America I'm hearing
Venezuela maybe I guess we could take a
guess at where else we're thinking of
most Cuba could be a possibility I don't
know pence is referring to this as if it
is a foregone conclusion and a mere
inevitability it's a question of where
will each of you end up rather than if
and this is part of the totally toxic
and destructive that this is military
industrial excuse me military industrial
complex
this is neoconservative American foreign
policy at its worst it's all of these
things that depend on and assume and are
fueled by the tacit acceptance that it's
just a matter of figuring out which Wars
we're going to get involved in or start
rather than actually evaluating whether
we should be involved in these sorts of
conflicts or engagements at all
extremely disturbing almost beyond words
and not reported widely which is why I'm
leading the show with it today I have
some really great video today of one of
the most prominent bad-faith
actors that have surfaced as
brown-nosing Donald Trump sycophants
during the last two years and I'm
talking of course about Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham the trump
presidency has been sort of great for
Lindsey Graham and also a complete and
total embarrassment for him so on the
one hand Trump has been great for
Lindsey Graham because Lindsey Graham
sucking up to Trump has gotten him tons
of airtime he's way more known today
than he was before the Trump presidency
and in a sense his sort of personal
profile has risen drastically under
Donald Trump on the other hand though
Lindsey Graham has been caught in
hilarious contradiction after
contradiction and if you're paying
attention you realize that Graham is a
completely farcical political tool with
no concern whatsoever for the truth or
for what's right and I told you back in
April you might remember that even
though Lindsey Graham now says Trump
can't be impeached for any cover-up
actions like for example obstruction
because there was no underlying crime
for example conspiracy to collude with
Russia or whatever we found video of
Lindsey Graham despite that from the
Clinton era where he was actually
renting on the Senate floor about how
Bill Clinton can be impeached even
though there was no underlying crime so
more recently I've told you that the
Trump administration is ignoring endless
subpoenas for documents and directing
witnesses to ignore subpoenas and
Lindsey Graham thinks that that's fine
as long as it's the Trump administration
but it turns out there's a Lindsey just
like there's a Trump tweet for anything
it seems that there's a Lindsey Graham
video for anything it turns out that
back in the late 1990s Graham also said
that ignoring congressional subpoenas or
directing others to do so is an
impeachable offense for a President of
the United States of course when the
president at the time happened to be
Democratic President Bill Clinton so Fox
News's Chris Wallace tried to call out
Lindsey Graham and it's pretty
interesting he plays the video for
Graham
gram doesn't really know which way is up
or what what's going on and what he
comes up with is just saying well the
difference is Republicans act in good
faith and Democrats act in bad faith
that that's basically what it comes down
to and this all has to do if you haven't
been following it and I really didn't
while I was on break but I've caught
myself up on it this all has to do with
Democrats trying to get more information
about the molar report redacted versions
unredacted versions bar etc and that
sets up the following exchange on fox
news you call all of what's going on
here in Washington a political circus
but you took it a different view back
when you were leading the impeachment
effort against Bill Clinton back in the
late 90s at that time you said that any
president and you talked specifically
about Clinton and Richard Nixon who
defied Congress when it came to
subpoenas was in danger of impeachment
here you are back then you're becoming
the judge and jury it is not your job to
tell us what we need it is your job to
comply all the things we need to provide
oversight over you question why is it an
impeachable offense for Clinton or Nixon
back then to ignore congressional
subpoenas but it's okay for President
Trump to do now
well there's two things here the Moller
investigation was a special counsel
appointed to find out if the president
committed a crime if he colluded with
the Russians if you obstructed justice
the president gave him 1.4 million
documents to Muller everybody around the
president was allowed to testify he
never claimed the executive privilege he
complied no cover-up work with Muller
mowers the final word on this for me
so if Clinton had stiff Ken Starr that's
different what Nadler is doing is trying
to destroy the president and his family
if I were the president I'd fight back
against this political revenge coming
out of the house Muller was the man of
the law Muller was an independent voice
that we all trusted to be fair I don't
trust House Democrats to be fair they're
trying to redo the Muller report they're
trying to make up other stuff and at the
end of the day it will be political
suicide for the
impeach if I were the president I would
fight Nadler tooth and nail I'm glad it
cooperated with Muller that's the
difference so Lindsey Graham's
explanation is when he was calling
people out in the 90s the Republican
Party was a responsible respectable good
faith actor and most importantly they
could be trusted not to act in a
politically biased way they were just
doing the right thing but 20 19
Democrats can't be trusted right
they are the political ones but
Republicans impeaching Clinton in the
1990s weren't being political I am
having a hard time imagining a more
outrageous explanation like if you said
come up with a more ridiculous way to
explain the contradiction I don't know
that I could do better than the
absurdity of what Lindsey Graham
actually said but I want to try to zoom
out a little bit and take like a bigger
picture view here rather than focusing
on the specifics of Lindsey Graham's
blatant and obvious political posturing
none of these elected officials have
your best interests in mind
meaning Democrats play political games
and Republicans play political games
Democrats play politics with subpoenas
and congressional testimony and
Republicans do the exact same thing
there were rampant politics around the
Bill Clinton impeachment and the Ken
Starr investigation no matter what
Lindsey Graham says and yes there are
rampant politics today from Democrats
around the Trump stuff but don't mistake
what I'm saying for me playing this both
sides do it equally sort of thing I'm
not doing the phone neutrality BS that
you might hear on some other shows the
pathetic fence sitting milquetoast
everybody is doing the same stuff on
both sides thing that adds nothing the
conversation that's not what I mean both
sides play politics with all of this but
when Republicans were doing it with Bill
Clinton it was about a lie related to
oral sex okay
Democrats are now using the same I admit
these are tired tactics these are
depressing political techniques but
Democrats are doing it to try to figure
out the full scope of what criminality
may have been undertaken by the
President of the United States and
people around him
to figure out the full scope of the
kleptocratic disaster that is this
administration that has been
participating in a deliberate self
enrichment and and and violations or
moves away from the systems of checks
and balances that we have so yeah both
sides do this garbage congressional
subpoenas are political tools a lot of
these things are political tools that
we've been seeing for decades on this uh
in this country but you have to
understand the pernicious role that
bottom feeders like Lindsey Graham have
in 2019 versus thinking back to the 90s
and what Bill Clinton's impeachment was
all about do not fall for this truly
moronic explanation for Lindsey Graham
now unfortunately Chris Wallace didn't
really follow up about the absurdity of
it but at least we got the clip that we
got let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at deep Ackman the show is on
twitter at david patten show the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so i'm going to have to start
thanking two new members per show
instead of one because by doing just one
per show we've fallen so far behind this
is a really good problem to have so let
me say thanks today to Alan show hot who
is today's first new member of the day
and also to Steven stack pool who is
today's second new member of the day and
then in addition let me thank today's
longtime sustaining member of the day
Crispin del Nero who has been with us
for almost five years
Alan Steven and Crispin really
appreciate your support do the right
thing support media that you believe is
important it's very inexpensive it makes
a big difference and it takes under a
minute at join pakman.com look forward
to welcoming you as the new member of
the day someday soon Donald Trump has
now denied that a North Korean missile
launch happened after also saying that
he's ok with the missile launch which
now he says didn't happen at least in
the way that is being reported and I've
got to take a little time to set this up
when I tell you about the horrible and
erratic geopolitical behavior of Donald
Trump I'm not telling it to you because
it's funny
I'm not telling it to you to score
political points and frankly there
aren't really political points to be
scored because everybody loses I mean
much of the country gets that this
presidency is a geopolitical foreign
policy disaster and those that don't get
that at this point in time aren't going
to be convinced if I do another story
about the embarrassing ignorant tweet
that Donald Trump posted or yet another
dumb thing that Donald Trump said but
hopefully I've given you some insight on
the show about the importance of the
geopolitical issues that are at stake or
at least some of them and one of those
issues is North Korea sort of in the
context of the Russia china-us
superpower love triangle or whatever you
want to call it and a couple of weeks
ago I explained it in a little bit of
detail I explained how
the United States has really fallen off
the world stage fault fallen on the
world stage fallen off of it you could
say whatever an allergy or metaphor you
want to use in the two years that Trump
has been president this has happened in
ways that are significantly more
far-reaching than Donald Trump and his
administration can fix right this is
something that's going to take a long
time to fix if indeed it's going to be
fixed and we are in the middle in all of
this of a sort of political realignment
geo policy of politics Germany now by
all measures is the leader of the free
world it's not a literal term don't get
mad at me look up what the term means
it's a colloquial term and Angela Merkel
the leader of Germany has sort of taken
the reins from the United States
president who usually holds that non
official title leader of the free world
and in the meantime what's likely to be
the big superpower fight of the next
decade between the United States and
China and Russia is really going Russia
and China's way in just about every
sense the u.s. is playing right into
Russia's hand with Trump slamming NATO
and criticizing our Western European
allies meanwhile the u.s. relationship
with China is deteriorating in part
because of this trade war that Donald
Trump is waging and losing and meanwhile
Russia and China are getting closer
they're making more industry deals and
trade deals and energy development deals
and they're putting the United States
assigned side increasingly and in the
middle of this we come to North Korea
which we're talking about today who
historically has had only China as its
primary pseudo ally it's not even really
always been an ally of North Korea China
but it's been an ally in some ways Trump
has held two summits with North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un in both Trump came
away extremely impressed with Kim's
sense of humor his intelligence his
negotiation skills but Trump got nothing
out of it vague promises at the first
summit nothing happened
second summit ended abruptly with no
progress but Trump just seemed smitten
but with Kim jong-un and it was reported
over this past weekend that North Korea
is launching missiles again Japan
United Nations Security Council Trump's
own National Security Advisor John
Bolton all sang North Korea has fired
ballistic missiles that violate the
United Nations Security Council
resolutions Trump first tweeted he's
okay with the launch and then later
denied that the launch took place at
least as described if it happened it's
fine but I don't think that it actually
happened even though everybody around me
is telling me that it happened Trump
tweeting first quote North Korea fired
off some small weapons which disturbed
some of my people and others but not me
I have confidence that Chairman Kim will
keep his promise to me by the way
chairman what exactly is he chairman of
and also smiled when he called swampman
joe biden a low IQ individual and worse
perhaps that's sending me a signal an
extremely unhinged tweet and instead of
taking the side of our ally Japan of his
own intelligence his own National
Security Advisor John Bolton Trump
taking the side of Chairman Kim and
using it as an opportunity to sort of
join with Kim jong-un in criticizing Joe
Biden so here the position at least
initially is the missile launch happened
but Trump says well it was small weapons
and it's okay but then Trump in Japan at
a joint press conference with Shinzo Abe
a trump just says oh yeah everybody else
is wrong the launch that I said is fine
really didn't happen Trump saying quote
my people think it could have been a
violation
I view it differently I view it as a man
perhaps he wants to get attention and
perhaps not who knows it doesn't matter
all I know is that there have been no
nuclear tests there have been no
ballistic missiles going out there have
been no long-range missiles going out he
knows that with nuclear that's never
going to happen only bad can happen he
understands he is a very smart man he
gets it understand that there's the
continued ignorant by Trump when it
comes to North Korea but now it's also
wrapped up with an insult to Japan
what while in Japan Trump is saying that
he believes apparently his own opinion
over what Japan believes and over our
own intelligence and over the United
Nations and over our own National
Security Advisor and then it becomes an
issue not just of Trump's geopolitical
skill which is close to zero as you can
probably tell but this becomes an issue
about Donald Trump's judgment which
aside from politics and aside from
Trump's position on abortion for example
aside from Trump's positions on issues
when you have a president that's so
significantly lacks in judgment it's
dangerous and that's what I want to talk
about next
so I already told you about Donald Trump
with another example of his just
terrible judgment initially saying that
he's fine with the North Korean missile
launch that later he says didn't
actually happen this is a serious
concern or at least it should be for the
movement that cares about rationality
and critical thinking and modern
geopolitical relationships and really
everything else under the umbrella of
what I like to call reality if you care
about reality if you want to operate in
a world where reality influences our
views and decisions and our sort of
place in the world as humans then you
have to recognize that the fact that
there's something very wrong with Donald
Trump's judgment is an existential risk
to the United States and when we look
back at all of these examples of Trump's
poor judgment I mean just to give you a
few Trump's repeated statements that he
believed Russian President Vladimir
Putin that Russia didn't interfere in
the 2016 US election that was Trump
using what he believes to be his good
judgment which is not to read a guy like
Vladimir Putin and to come away saying I
believe him I trust them I think he's
telling me the truth of course we now
have endless dozens and dozens of
assessments and the Moller report and
everything else which tells us actually
American intelligence conclusions were
right from the beginning about Russian
interference that one we talked about a
lot we just talked about the North Korea
example five minutes ago Trump said he
doesn't think that Kim jong-un and the
regime did anything in vial
of the UN Security Council resolutions
with the recent launch you'll remember
that Donald Trump also said he doesn't
believe that anybody high up at North
Korea in North Korea had anything to do
with or even awareness of what happened
with the death of otto warmbier remember
when Donald Trump said this I know the
warmbier family very well I think
they're an incredible family what
happened is horrible
I really believe something very bad
happened to him and I don't think that
the top leadership know about it and
when they had to send him home by the
way I got the prisoners back I got the
hostages back and Otto was one of the
hostages but I don't came back in shape
that was not even to be talked about I
find it I thought it was horrible
now the others came back extremely
healthy but Otto came back in a
condition that was just just terrible
and I will I I did speak about it and I
don't believe that he would have allowed
that to happen just wasn't to his
advantage to allow that to happen
kim jeong-hoon or at least the top
leadership knows when there are
Americans being held in North Korea
their value is huge to the North Korean
propaganda machine and it is an
absolutely absurd assertion that Donald
Trump made and another example of his
poor judgment there's lots of other
examples where it's more a question of
is Trump's judgment bad or is he just
dumb like when he said Mexico is going
to pay for the wall any sensible person
realized they were never going to pay
for it it just wasn't going to happen
and Donald Trump insisted that they were
is that bad judgment is that being dumb
is that deliberately lying I'm not
really sure Trump had the bad judgment
to choose Michael Flynn as a national
security adviser despite having been
warned multiple times by multiple people
including Barack Obama about Michael
Flynn we know how that ended with
Michael Flynn indicted Trump had the bad
judgment to attack John McCain endlessly
even after John McCain died the
disastrous judgment which led Trump to
start this endless unwinnable trade war
with China which allows Russia to swoop
in and improve their relationship with
China increasingly leaving the United
States out to pasture the limitless bad
judgment of violating the Iran deal even
though Iran didn't violate the deal
which as I told you two weeks ago is now
leading Iran to resume researching
nuclear technology predictable and an
internally logical move from Iran's
point of view and the more I think about
it I actually don't know whether these
are examples of bad judgment or of Trump
being simply ignorant or of Donald Trump
being a bad person but in either case
it's the mother lode of bad decisions
and bad positions that are coming from
Donald Trump's inability or
unwillingness to actually judge
situations for what they are
we're sort of in a 1984 esque
era in that way I know that in the last
couple years I've said that a lot of
elements of what's going on today are
less like 1984 and more like brave new
world by Aldous Huxley this particular
thing is more a 1984 thing right war is
peace freedom is slavery ignorance is
strength everything's backwards nothing
is as it seems and Donald Trump even
said that trying to remember something
like what you were seeing and hearing
you shouldn't believe or you can't
believe what you were seeing and hearing
it's good to be back from my vacation
and my trip because we've got to get
down to business with removing this
menace because it is becoming
extraordinarily belligerent and
significantly more urgent particularly
as these long-term relationships are
broken and bad decisions are made and
it's going to take whoever replaces
Trump Bibi it in two years I guess more
like a year and a half now whether it's
in a year and a half or in five and a
half years whoever ultimately replaces
Donald Trump is going to have years of
work to do to fix the problems that
Donald Trump has created make sure
you're following the David Pakman show
on Instagram to vote in this week's poll
at David Pakman show we'll take a quick
break and be back with much much more
right after this it's great to be back
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today Anna Merlin who is a senior
reporter at Geo Media Group and author
of the new book Republic of Lies and are
so great to talk to you today thanks for
having me
so we spoke I guess now it was a couple
of weeks ago with Nancy rosenbloom from
Harvard University about the rise in
conspiracism sort of separate from
specific conspiracy theories in a sense
and the the sort of underlying societal
issues that come with that etc I want to
talk with you a little bit about the way
in which the theories themselves have
kind of evolved over time and then maybe
we can dig into the impact of that I
mean give us a general sense like where
did conspiracy theories start how have
they changed in the last hundred years
in the last five years mm-hmm
well conspiracy theories have always
been a part of society and they've
especially always been a part of
American society from the outset what we
know is that up until World War two most
ordinary people's conspiracy theories
were about outside groups what they
perceived as outside groups whether that
was communists masons Jews you know some
kind of paranoia about these outside
groups seizing control and then after
World War one is the federal government
got bigger most ordinary people's
conspiracy theories started to center
around the government's often who was
really in charge and what the government
was really doing um I would say that in
the last five years the main change that
we've seen is the number of people who
are trying to make money off of some
type of conspiracism what I and other
people refer to as conspiracy
entrepreneurs people who see some kind
of Avenue for fame or success through
spreading what some folks would consider
to be conspiratorial ideas are there
that's super interesting actually are
there particular types or specific
conspiracy theories that are
particularly profitable and if so why I
wouldn't say so no I mean what we know
is that most people tend to
you feel more comfortable with
conspiracy theories that line up with
where they are politically and socially
already so you know conspiracy theories
garner support from people on the right
if they are right leaning the same with
on the Left what I do see however is
that most people can't make money as
conspiracy entrepreneurs solely from
just going on YouTube are having a
periscope they're really successful ones
are people like Alex Jones who also sell
a product Alex Jones you know I think
most people know by now most of the
money that he makes is from sales of
supplements and other products that are
sort of nominally health oriented yeah
there are I mean a lot of conspiracy
theories have nothing to do with
religion per se but it's interesting
that one of the ways that some of these
religious media outlets are also
monetizing is by using sort of I don't
know whether the conspiracy theory is
the right term but but sort of
apocalyptic fears and rapture sort of
imagery and that type of thing also to
be selling a product and it seems that
that is a sort of integral part of the
entrepreneurship component yeah it's
very common and you'll see a lot of
overlap among those groups there is a
big sort of apocalyptic especially
Christian element and a lot of American
right-wing conspiracy culture but I mean
fundamentally one of the core aspects of
conspiracism is this idea that some
massive consequential damaging change is
right around the corner and that if
action is not taken right now something
terrible would have will happen which is
of course a really profitable way to
sell all kinds of things is by creating
this sense of urgency and fear and panic
can you give an example of I mean I
don't know no that I necessarily want to
brand all conspiracy theories as either
sort of a real-world dangerous or
real-world harmless it seems there's
probably some kind of spectrum but at
least to kind of get into that
discussion can you give an example of a
prevalent conspiracy theory that does
not seem to connect to sort of like
real-world danger either for the
believers in it or for others bystanders
as we might call them and then on the
other side one that does have
significant real-world consequences mmm
like you say it's really really hard to
classify things that way because
a lot of people have sort of overlapping
conspiratorial beliefs you know a lot of
times people will antal enter through
one subculture and end up elsewhere and
it's really hard to tell who is going to
take real world damaging actions I mean
for instance Flat Earth is the
subculture that is very small but it is
growing we know there are more flat
earthers than there were a few years ago
and on its surface that one is pretty
silly but it is harmless more or less
you know it's a little bit alarming but
it is harmless however I and other
people who cover this have noted that
there is a lot of Cola cost denial in
those worlds that something about flat
earther ism tends to lead to a kind of
question everything mentality that goes
into some really weird and potentially
dark places and of course once you get
into Holocaust denial you're more
susceptible to white nationalist ideas
right um so it can be really hard to say
but yeah on its face Flat Earth is
probably not a huge cause for concern I
would say things like Pizza Gaiden Q and
I on the other hand have been mostly
harmless but obviously there have been
some pretty sizable exceptions to that
mainly Edgar Welch who went to comment
ping-pong in DC the supposed site of
this democrat run child sex slave ring
with a gun you know intent on saving
children and so I would say that the the
subcultures that make me the most
nervous are obviously the ones that are
tight with tied with white nationalism
and extremism as well as the ones that
brand their enemies as child abusers
because when you are talking about child
abuse when you were accusing someone of
being a pedophile or someone who hurts
children it justifies any kind of action
against them there is almost nothing
that isn't justified to stop that kind
of behavior and so it sets up this very
apocalyptic potentially violent rhetoric
that does make me a little bit nervous
here's what I don't understand about the
sort of transfer from one conspiracy
theory to belief in another so you
mentioned the idea of you get in through
Flat Earth and then all of a sudden you
end up with like Holocaust denial why do
we
seem to see and if it exists I would
love to hear about it you don't see
people who for example enter via Flat
Earth and then come to the realization
that huge corporations that benefit from
cheap immigrant labor love the idea that
there is this sort of argument or debate
between low and middle income people and
immigrants over who is actually
responsible for keeping wages low and
stealing jobs that's a real thing where
we have these huge corporations
benefitting by sort of fomenting that
battle right you don't really see the
traditional conspiracy theorists ever
end up with that one which happens to be
true they end up with something more
cartoonish like Holocaust denial why is
that the path and not the one that I
mentioned I mean it could be that some
individual conspiracy consumers do come
to more or less the place that you're
talking about you know people who for
instance entered through something like
9/11 truther ISM from the documentary
loose change you know which is pretty
influential for a bunch of people in
that world not all of those people
became hardcore 9/11 truthers some of
them came to believe that there was yeah
as you say just a political and social
reason why those why those conspiracy
theories spread I think really I would
say that we don't see people sort of
loudly and publicly leaving conspiracy
communities for a more reality based
version of the world because it the
algorithms that spread conspiracy
theories don't really reward those kinds
of claims or proclamations somebody who
is a really really big conspiracy
youtuber just sort of doesn't have any
particular
motivation to come out and say that they
were wrong and they've actually come to
a different and more grounded view of
the world can you quantify in any way
the effect that the Trump president
presidency has had on belief in
conspiracy theories in conspiratorial
thinking so we know that conspiracy
theories wax and wane in America
depending on sort of times of social
upheaval times of social and people's
social unrest when we're questioning who
we are as people we tend to see a rise
in
conspiracism and typically whatever
political party is
power is more prone to conspiracy
theorizing so we see a little bit more
of it on the left and we did during the
Obama years what is really unique about
the term presidency of course is that he
himself uses conspiracy theories and
spreads them and seems to see them as a
way to solidify his base solidify
support for him and to try to identify a
common enemy to encourage his supporters
to be mad at you know instead of him um
a scapegoat which is something that we
see a lot in more authoritarian
countries it's unusual but not unheard
of for a u.s. president and it really
sort of raises the stakes of what
conspiracy theories mean you know if
Trump wakes up tomorrow and decides to
start tweeting that vaccines cause
autism or you know that Q really done by
the way which he's previously done yes
he previously did that before he was
president and has not talked about it
too much since he's become president
which is a very good thing but yeah if
he wakes up and decides to start
promoting a more virulent conspiracy
theory from the Oval Office that will
have huge effects obviously you
mentioned that it's it's unusual but not
without precedent to see a president
pushing stuff like this what are other
examples of presidents I mean Nixon is
obviously the most obvious example of a
conspiracy theorist president he was
someone who believed you know that there
was a communist plot against him that
was actually orchestrated by Jews um
when Andrew Jackson someone tried to
assassinate Andrew Jackson and he came
to believe that it was functionally the
deep state you know functionally that
there was some kind of plot within
government to assassinate him instead of
a lone gunman so we see it like here and
there throughout American history um
something that is really sort of unusual
about Trump is that we can see it in
real time and we can see it via social
media how he's attempting to sort of use
these theories for his own gain yeah
that's been a definite change in terms
of the environment around the president
for sure absolutely fascinating stuff
we've been speaking with Anna Marie Anne
who is a senior reporter at Geo Media
Group also author of the new book
Republic of Lies which I
encourage you to check out Anna thank
you so much for talking to me today
thank you for having me I appreciate it
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
there is an effort being made by the
current administration and by the people
surrounding it to redefine what treason
is and it's genuinely menacing when we
see these authoritarian slides we have
to understand that they're often slow
slides it's the slow erosion of what it
means to have a truly free and
independent press for example and gets
chipped away at a little bit at a time
by the idea of suing media outlets
journalism licenses stricter White House
press past policies the smears about
fake news it's a long list but they're
really slow attempt less and less
frequent a press briefings by the White
House press secretary it's a slow
process that you have to observe from
afar rather than day to day another
example the slow erosion of the
independence of our branches of
government and the systems of checks and
balances including the investigative
power of the House and Senate ignoring
subpoenas getting your own attorney
general in there to manage the results
of an investigation into you etc etc etc
so it's important to realize that these
things happen slowly and it can be I
don't even know if this is an actual
thing but you often hear about the frog
that goes into a cold pan you start
heating up the pan heats up slowly the
Frog doesn't realize it's being burned
that may not even work maybe the Frog
just jumps out when it gets hot but
that's the metaphor that I think many of
us are familiar with and there is now a
slow but very sure and creeping slide to
redefine treason by the administration
yesterday
Donald Trump published or retweeted an
article that quotes Liz Cheney the
daughter of former Vice President Dick
Cheney as saying that statements made by
agents investigating Donald Trump could
be treason and in the length interview
Liz Cheney even says that FBI agents who
investigated Trump could have been
attempting a coup these are attempts at
redefinition if you control the language
you control everything I forget who
where that quote is from they are trying
to control the language treason treason
is the crime of betraying one's country
especially by attempting to kill the
sovereign or overthrow the government
that is not what the investigations into
Donald Trump sought to do they certainly
weren't attempting to kill the sovereign
and they were not attempting to
overthrow the government they were
investigating whether Donald Trump
specifically committed crimes a coup is
a sudden violent and illegal seizure of
power from a government of course those
investigating Donald Trump didn't
attempt to do that and if Donald Trump
were to leave there would be no seizure
of power from a government it would
likely be Mike Pence takes over although
there are other scenarios as well so
what you have to understand is that they
are systematically trying to change the
meaning of these things in order to
favor their position on whatever in this
case these investigations and in fact
Donald Trump was asked about his treason
claim recently a few days ago and look
at what happened and in further fact I
should mention as far as Liz Cheney is
concerned Liz Cheney if she wants to
talk about treason the closest thing to
treason she might be well-positioned to
comment on would be the war crimes that
her dad Dick Cheney participated in
within the Bush administration and even
then it is dubious whether you could
actually make a treason case there as
many legal experts have said so here's
Donald Trump asked about treason is
punishable by death who exactly are you
talking about - she says treason is
punishable by death you've accused your
adversaries of treason who specifically
are you accusing of treason well I think
a number of people and I think what you
look is that they have unsuccessfully
tried to take down the wrong person if
you look at Comey if you look at McCabe
if you look at probably people hot
people higher than that if you look at
struck if you look at his lover lisa
page his wonderful lover the two lovers
they talked openly you know they didn't
use their private server because they
didn't want to get caught so they used
the government server that was not a
good move he talked about the insurance
policy just in case crooked Hillary
losses and that didn't work out too well
for them so you look at them they want
an insurance policy so that should she
for any reason Allah
remember 100 million to one maybe he
said 100 million to nothing but should
she lose we'll have an insurance policy
and we'll get this guy out of office and
that's what they said and that's what
they meant that's treason that's treason
they couldn't win the election and
that's what happened and that's what's
happening right now because without the
treason word I guess but that's what's
happening now James Comey John McCain
Peter struck who was working for Muller
and was dismissed when politically
biased private text messages went public
as far as Democrats not thinking they
can win without trying to removed from
forcibly or whatever it's the opposite
it's been Trump who has been saying
Democrats can't win fair and square in
2020 which is how Trump has been hinting
at the possibility of not accepting the
results of the election if he loses this
is complete and total projection and
there's a real question here I don't
know the answer to this if a president
publicly accused you of treason by name
is there any recourse is that defamation
the act of damaging the good reputation
of someone slander or libel when the
president says that specific individuals
have committed a crime but not just any
crime the crime of treason is there any
recourse that those individuals have and
is that really where we are right now
we've got to take control back there's
no other way around it this is becoming
extremely dangerous and these
redefinitions should be concerning to
everybody who's been paying attention to
what's going on and this is not
happening by accident this is a
concerted effort to start throwing
around the word treason particularly at
a time when what we are learning is that
there was wrongdoing by Trump remember
and everybody around him it's an attempt
to distract from that and instead say
the investigators are the individuals
who were treasonous we can't fall for it
and we've got to act sooner than later
November of 2020 in order to stop this
insanity
speaking of voting in November by the
way Texas has had an Acting Secretary of
State and this man named
David Whitley of course a Republican has
now resigned after wrongly questioning
the citizenship of almost 100,000 people
and even more hilarious is that in his
resignation letter he didn't even
mention the botched voter purge that
took place in Texas at all the
resignation letter is a blatant
whitewashing of what actually happened
the voter purge was actually ended back
in April and there was a settlement that
was reached with civil rights groups who
sued over it and what's even more insane
about all of this is that under the
terms of the agreement that was reached
over this voter purge the next Secretary
of State whoever it ends up being can
keep trying to identify non-citizens and
remove them from the voter rolls as long
as they put in place some better
screening methods so that they get more
accurate results now that piece actually
makes sense I mean if you zoom out
states should be allowed to remove
non-citizens from voter rolls that
that's perfectly reasonable the problem
is that in practice it's been made
crystal clear that it's a tactic
motivated by voter suppression to help
Republicans period the way it went down
is that they claim to have found 95,000
non-citizens registered to vote they
started sending these lists out to the
individual county officials to start
pulling those people off of the voter
rolls and then very quickly they
admitted and a court agreed oh yeah that
list was bogus it wasn't actually made
up of non-citizens registered to vote
but of course by then it was too late to
stop the propaganda war effect Donald
Trump was tweeting about it saying look
rampant voter fraud here's an example
from Texas and Trump actually claimed
that of those 95,000 non-citizens
who were supposedly identified by Texas
58,000 voted and of course everything
was a lie a federal judge ruled that way
saying there wasn't widespread voter
fraud and this Whitley guys strategy was
a complete and total mess so here are
the key takeaways number one this is all
part of the untrue story that Trump's
been telling us since November of 2016
and Republicans have been telling us for
even longer than that that millions of
people are voting illegally with Trump
specifically it was three to five
million people voted illegally Hillary
and didn't really win the popular vote
it was because of those three to five
million illegal votes this is so
laughably false at this point that I
don't even want to spend that much time
on it the more important thing to
understand here is that we can't let the
right play games with this to make it
seem as though we on the left want
people to vote illegally okay because
every time we call out the horrible
implementation of these strategies that
the right does deliberately to
disenfranchise likely Democratic voters
or those more likely to be Democratic
voters they will say hold on lefties are
you saying you want people voting
illegally you're saying you don't want
to remove people who aren't citizens
from voter rolls see you're part of the
problem so we've got to be prepared to
take that head-on and the answer is the
position is obvious of course we want
only legal voters voting and
overwhelmingly that's what happens every
major study has found that fraudulent
votes are almost non-existent they're
statistically insignificant when it
comes to the results of actual elections
the reason that we are correct to be
suspicious and disgusted with
Republicans doing this stuff is not
because we want the legal votes it's
because it's not a problem and the right
has admitted behind closed doors and we
even have video of them admitting it in
public in in some cases they are doing
all of this to hurt the left higher
turnout helps the helps the left more
voting helps the left voting access
helps the left so don't allow them to
change the narrative we're against
illegal voters they barely exist though
and the real issue is voter suppression
it's not voter fraud and this has been a
at this point I don't know it is could
we say it's a multi-decade effort to
suppress votes in a way that is
strategically advantageous to
Republicans don't let them play the
games a good that this guy Whitley has
resigned bad that he was able to
whitewash the resignation with this
bogus resignation letter and now we've
got to see who it is that the governor
Abbott is going to nominate probably
won't be out until after the 2020
election we have a voicemail number
number is two one nine two David P take
a listen to this voicemail that came in
about social democracy and technological
unemployment
hey David my name is Justin I'm from
Washington State my question is as a
social democrat should we be opposed to
automation taking service jobs away from
working-class people thank you okay so
this is a really good question whether
you're a social democrat or not the the
right answer here is a simple one
historical efforts to oppose technology
on the basis that it would destroy jobs
have failed period we could probably
find some examples where there has been
a successful effort to suppress a
technology at least temporarily on the
basis that it would destroy jobs but
historically saying we need to suppress
this coming technology because people
will lose their jobs has not worked what
we need to take seriously is rethinking
the relationship of humans to work for
example technological automation if you
imagine a business with a hundred
employees technological automation could
make 50 of those employees unnecessary
and one way that the business could
respond would be to say we're replacing
50 employees with machines we're keeping
50 employees 50 people lose their jobs
it doesn't have to go that way the other
way that it could be done is the
business says well what we're going to
do is keep all of our hundred employees
but they'll each work only two and a
half days a week or four hours a day
instead of eight or whatever else now
obviously the business is not going to
be willing to use the entire gain from
the technology and and give it all to
the workers but maybe they say we'll
keep our hundred employees and they can
work six or five hours a day instead of
eight and we will sort of split the
gains from the technology now obviously
there needs to be some reason that the
business would choose to do that and
there are people including Bill Gates
who have started floating ideas and and
sort of thinking about different ways in
which we might be able to make that
happen but no I think that it's not only
misguided I think most importantly it's
a futile effort to try to oppose the
technology on the basis that jobs will
be lost we need to rethink how the gains
from these technologies should be
distributed and that's
where 90% of the issue is okay I will
tell a bunch of vacation stories on the
bonus show today including to dog poop
stories I don't know that we've ever
really had dog poop stories on the show
and I regularly visit Argentina so it
makes it all the more incredible that
there haven't been dog poop stories on
the show anybody who's walked around
when a cytus will understand what I mean
but I do have two dog poop stories today
and a whole bunch of other stuff become
a member or a patron to get instant
access to the bonus check
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]